apache beam is built to handle large
amounts of data but what happens when
you need to group data together or even
work with multiple data sets let's go
over a few different ways that you can
join data in bean
[Music]
to get things started let's look at a
simple example grouping data on a
specific key we'll use some data from an
e-commerce website that shows which
items a user viewed
each row in this p collection represents
a user viewing a specific item from the
store
the first column shows the id of the
user and the second column shows a
unique id of the item that they viewed
if you're just looking for a count of
items you don't need to do anything
fancy using beam's count aggregation
does exactly what it sounds like and
counts the number of elements of course
you'll probably also want to look at
each user independently so you can count
per key to get the number of items each
user looked at
while that's fine for getting the number
of elements you might also want the
actual elements themselves that could
give you an idea for what types of item
each user was most interested in so you
could give personalized recommendations
for that you'll want to use group by key
group by key is a beam transform that
will take a p collection and group all
of the values for each key
with the key of user id group by key
gives us a list of all the items that
each user viewed so now we can use this
information to do further processing in
beam or another system to generate
recommendations after all it's pretty
easy to see that user 1 is into cameras
grouping by key inside of a single p
collection is simple enough but what
happens when you join that collection
with even more data
let's take a look at another set of
example data
now we're looking at a p collection of
users and the physical stores they've
bought things from
just like before we have our user id as
the first column and the store id as the
second column
however the store id doesn't give us
much information to work off of does it
that's because the store information is
stored somewhere else
this pattern is sometimes called
relational data where the id is used as
a reference to another collection or
table where the other data is stored
here we're storing some additional
information for the store like the id
number for the point of sale system and
the address of the store
in order to get the data joined together
efficiently you can consider how much
data you're looking to join with your
primary data
we know that we'll have lots of items in
the first collection which grows each
time a purchase happens
but our store information won't change
nearly as often
in fact the store data can probably fit
into memory which means beam can
efficiently hold onto our stored data as
a side input
this is similar to a broadcast drawing
in other systems
remember that beam is designed to handle
distributed and large data processing so
using a site input keeps the data in
memory on the workers and avoids needing
to do a shuffle operation on the data
joining our user order data with our
store side input gives us the user id
combined with the store information we
need
now we can hand this off for further
processing
but what would we do if we wanted to
join with the order information as well
if our orders data set is too large and
won't fit into memory a side input won't
work for that we'll need to join larger
sets of data
there's actually a few different ways
beam allows for making joins but we
recommend using schemas whenever
possible
schemas provide a type system for beam
records that are independent of any
specific programming language type in
our example data we can use the order id
as our key
in java our schema for the purchase data
might look like this where we have
different fields for our collections
including the user's id and the order id
we can combine that with a schema for
orders which will also include the order
id as well as the products they
purchased
joining these together using order id is
the key will return rows that contain
all the information from each collection
which is perfect for further processing
we'll have a link in the description for
more information about schemas and how
to use them if you're not able to use
schemas you can use co-group by key
the data is aggregated by shared keys
across multiple collections however the
syntax can be more verbose especially
when you're working with complex data
structures so it's definitely
recommended to try and use schemas when
possible
so far we've been looking at examples
for joining together bounded sets of
data for batch processing
but you can still join batch and
streaming data together using most of
the same logic if you're working with
streaming data like our previous
physical store example and you need to
join with a small set of data like the
store locations you can still use the
side inputs
you can use a global window for your
site input and join it with your
windowed streaming data the side inputs
global window will be projected onto the
streaming data windows
even if the side input sometimes changes
like when a new store is added there's a
pattern for dealing with a slowly
updating side input i'll put a link that
has some more details in the description
but it's essentially just an additional
step to update the site input since the
data is stored in memory it's most
efficient to only update this when you
need to which will depend on what type
of data you're storing if you're joining
your streaming data with something
larger than a side input and it updates
regularly then you're looking at it
joining two sets of streaming data
in that case you'll need to consider how
your data is being windowed i know
that's a lot of information if you'd
like to get more hands-on and try some
of this out for yourself check out the
notebook that's linked in the
description we'll also include links to
the documentation for the other topics
we discussed today thanks for watching
you